hey everyone Pixar's Incredibles - is
now in theaters and we are here with our
review do you think credible just give
us the best superhero action of the year
and what is it about Pixar the mixer
movie it's just so charming even when
they're sequels of movies that came out
14 years ago it just doesn't matter
because it's still good but we'll get to
the deeper reasons of why we liked it
and maybe some stuff that we wanted more
of because it's not a perfect movie but
we're gonna get to all of those deeper
reasons and thoughts about it but first
guys welcome to new rockstars news it's
our deep dive into all the biggest
stories this week that you need to know
about so we're also gonna talk about our
first look at Aquaman and some big
Avengers news news about the game of
Thrones prequel series coming out and
more I'm Erik Bosse joining me at the
table are Sam basher over here and
billowing over here and back to Erik
buzz in the middle where he feels
comfortable but actually before we get
started the big news a quick big
announcement new rock stars will be at
VidCon next week oh yeah that's all this
a philip and sam me a mod will be there
- we'll all be around Devon fan favorite
we're very very excited we'll be at the
Anaheim Convention Center from Thursday
through Saturday we're just so excited
to meet all you guys if you'll be there
and we're gonna be handing out free
stuff I don't want to say what it is
yeah we made specific stuff like custom
stuff for you guys if you come find us
and we will give you some but we're also
going to have an event well just say
we're gonna try to shoot a live show
there yeah and we want you guys to be
there with us live audience and like
no-holds-barred like there'll be no
bleeping no weapon checks like anything
could happen that's not true there are
many weapons yeah but find us follow us
on social media on Twitter Instagram
will post all about this of where
exactly it's gonna take place that part
is still being negotiated but I mean if
we have to do it like in the alley in
the back yeah we'll do it yeah we'll
make it happen
metaphor but focus in the face I do with
all my vlog my screen I'm like I wish I
could just poke this person yeah and I
can't and also it's illegal to do that
in real life yeah make sure it Apollo's
each individually on social media and
follow our channels at new rock stars on
on Twitter and Instagram and Facebook
because we're gonna be posting like
crazy just a minute two minute updates
of where we'll be so come find us and
talk to us we're so excited meet you
guys we love that time John we'll be
there alright well let's consider with
our top story our review of Incredibles
2 now we're gonna get to the deeper
reasons of what we liked about this
movie what it could have done better and
we're gonna discuss the story in detail
so it's best to consider this a spoiler
review if you haven't seen it yet go
watch it then come meet us back here but
don't worry it's not like a twist late
in movie it's you know it's just like a
fun animated film it's not like bomb
show movie ruin for me but yeah it's
always better if you watch it first
right but let's get started with what we
think Incredibles 2 did really well what
do we like about the movie it's just so
you did a know you put out a video about
hereditary this week on the channel and
I had seen that and I felt physically
ill and I got a it was I was fortunate
to get like an early screening for this
and it was just like the day after and
it was just like it was just nice you
know the score at Michael chiquinho
figured out how to say his name properly
he's coming back again to do his score
once he and heat it up and he's done a
lot of the Pixar movies either the Star
Trek movies he's done a lot of JJ Abrams
stuff he's extremely talented as soon as
you hear that you see the stylistic
opening of the Disney logo you're just
like I love this there's probably a
proper name for the art style of this
movie I always feel like Jetsons s quite
good is a retro for sure yeah and it's
just like some about it not just that
it's a revisit of a world we've already
been to like when we were growing up
it's just that something about it is
just so sweet and genuine and you can
just see how much care was put into it
it's like like when you don't get fast
food and you go and sit down and I get
like a home-cooked meal type of
restaurant feel it's just like it feels
good it feels hearty like a big Italian
dinner that's what this movie is like
it's just like a lot of carbs you know
it's probably I shouldn't watch this all
the time but it's nice movies nice yeah
I enjoy I actually enjoyed it more than
the first movie yeah well I think it was
good reason I actually think that the
thing good cuz it Sam covered a lot
actually that that
we're loading with that I agree with
that and I think it's because Pixar has
a straight direct line to our hearts
like especially when it has to do with
family and family dynamic where the
moment you're like he's trying to be a
good dad and like they're so good at
that I in so quickly
that's always what gets me is like we
don't know these characters that well
right we've spent two hours with them
before word before this and like now I'm
just like no that's his thing he always
wanted you know like I feel like I know
them so well and I think that's a lot of
the artwork too you know the short that
played before before it Wow Wow yeah
yeah sweet was also like like
heart-wrenching and it again they do
this in minutes so they become masters
of being able to do it in minutes and
then when you get a movie it's like oh
my god I'm feeling so many things the
other thing that I'll say that this
movie does surprisingly well for an
animated kids movie is also specifically
the opening and middle action set-pieces
so essentially like the big dramatic
fights we'll call them are like actually
like pretty damn good you're just like
whoa these are these belong in the
Marvel Universe and someone I'm gonna
look even better than some of those so
and they're very creative about my
favorite thing is when they find the
ways to use the powers and like a like a
in a way that has resonance to like
other choices so right now the one who's
coming to mind is splitting the last two
girls bike into yeah and like they're
like that would make sense this
character is limited by a beam on a
motorcycle unless the motorcycle can
also be split but we're just like that's
such a great extra degree that they go -
yeah I think the way I see it is Pixar
is better than pretty much any other
movie studio when it comes to charm and
storytelling just purely through design
choices right so like every movie is
visual storytelling because we're just
looking at visual choices and acting and
set design choices but like Pixar every
little choice is a design choice that
somehow tells the story in a way from
the way the characters costumes look
from the way Edna modes head is shaped
there's like little humor choices and
fun action set pieces that are composed
just from a base level of how the
characters are designed you talked about
the bike split in two
I think just
the design of the portals in Boyd the
character Floyd and how they can get so
much fun out of just structuring a
number of set pieces just great portal
is they added portal rules to it right
where I was like increased momentum to
as you fall through and if you keep
balling through the same void it's like
you're going faster faster so just also
really know it kind of boiled down a lot
of the stuff we would maybe find flaws
and in other more like I just enjoyed
how they express the last girl's powers
because sometimes whenever you see like
stretchy power just like they're gonna
get longer and shorter and that's not
only gonna do it's like no it's
fantastic so one of the hardest
character to portray coolest abilities
because she can like she's the ultimate
spy and choosing to do the motorcycle
that can split apart is a good example
of how her powers like work exactly
because she wouldn't use a car she
probably wouldn't fly she wants
something they can like weave in and out
just like her powers can and it was just
I like the reasoning why she was the
star as well like of course make the mom
the star I get I get the logic of like
you had the dad now it's the mom's term
but also just as a financial standpoint
like she is the hero that would cost
that cause the least amount of damage
because she can slip in and out of
places without hurting anybody yeah I
really like the way this movie picked up
immediately after the first movie left
off like they're dealing with the
immediate consequences I think a lot of
times when you see sequels they jump
ahead and they just kind of like leave
those questions unanswered that that
whatever but the fact that you have Brad
Bird directing in both this movie and in
the sequel and it's the same Pixar
creative team behind it they're able to
just like pick up immediately where they
left off with the question of the guy
who asked out violet you know Tony and
the under minors attack like we're
literally we're it's it's like you could
put these movies back to back and it's
one continuous story that's like five
hours of fun you know and the opening
sequence of the under minor it's it's
just so well put together and they just
like they didn't really figure out all
the things they need to figure out from
the first maybe write of how to be
heroes in this modern world where being
a superheroes is illegal that question
wasn't really fixed at the end of the
movie it just seemed like it was kind of
presented like oh but what if you know
now this family is gonna work together
we still see them have to solve this
kind of problem and then it's still very
much illegal and they are they're a
little messy with it and they let the
get away they don't solve the problem
they cause even by the way he's still
out there mm-hmm miners still out in
this protest not just screen slaver but
I they there's always a great attention
to detail with Pixar and it's not just
attention to detail with like you know
little design things and prop placement
and the way characters are shaped but
like with the story there's a lot of
attention to detail with the story and
leaving thing no stone is left unturned
and no dovetail is left undone tailed
something else I you bring up a good
point about like how they design certain
scenes there's a scene where the dad's
on the phone with the mom and the moms
doing missions and he's just trying to
like hold it together because he does
kinda have a great moment or he's like
I'm mr. incredible I do I'm it's in the
name like I have to be the best at this
and you see just like each like crisis
each kid is in and like it's just like
she walks in and she's invisible so
she's pouting and you're like that's a
nightmare I don't know how to deal with
that - is zooming around he's not paying
attention to his homework and Jack Jack
Jack Jack so he's like why won't you go
to sleep it's such a good it was just
such a good way to use their powers to
express their own like point in their
life and like what kind of like what
it's like to deal with a kid like a kid
who's growing up like a young boy who's
growing up they wants to get into sports
and like he's always running around and
making a mess and the girl who's going
through adolescence doesn't make the
joke about that and like just figuring
out how to handle her emotions also
trying to deal with this
Tonie crisis as well and the baby is so
predictable cuz you're still trying to
learn and since he was not an absent
parent but he was little parent who was
going out and doing a job and wasn't at
home as much he doesn't know all the ins
and outs of dealing with Jack Jack so
I'm glad that like in one scene it was
like maybe 10 seconds you got a good
exam Incredibles head space for like
three-quarters of the movie yeah well
let's move on cuz this was not a perfect
film right and I was interested to hear
you Sam say that you'd like to bear in
the first movie I personally like the
first movie a little bit better but that
might just be me I kind of tend to like
all these Pixar's first movies better
than the the second one like Toy Story
Toy Story I feel that way really Finding
Nemo I prefer the originals the first
car is of course but that's an easy
board clear but I
I don't think this is a perfect move so
let's get to some things that we wish
could have been cleared up a little bit
better
I kind of want to say real quick just is
like a sight a to our audience we are
like such big fans of this kind of
content and that means that we like to
look at it like thoroughly and we know
why we love it and we just spent you
know close to ten minutes talking about
like what we loved about this and then
so every time we review a movie we're
also going to tell you stuff we don't
like about it and that is not us looking
too deep into it that is you having to
face that every movie might have some
issues and we can't hide issues because
if we did then we would just be chills
hmm and I don't like being a shill so
here's what I didn't like yeah all right
there's three things I'm increasing
order of rage one is it's pretty small
actually it's just I think this has to
be probably the last movie that explores
the idea of wait maybe superheroes are
causing more damage than good
so maybe it should be illegal to be a
superhero it's like we get it
Man of Steel really messed up the world
around it also the fun of that narrative
it really kind of just bummed that out a
little bit yeah
so so now though we're kind of a little
bit in a place we're like okay I don't
think we need to explore that question
anymore of like our superheroes things
we should have it's like yes we go to
the box office but like we want to see
them to just a little bit worse is
inconsistent power uses of Elastigirl
she is the star of this movie for sure
like she gets all the action and enough
times her problems aren't solved with
her powers that she just had a second
earlier and like here's a really easy
one to see just in a quick moment is she
has to like run her arm down under a
door then up and then unlock a series of
locks in order to open that door but a
second earlier we had seen that she
could completely flatten her body and
like move in so she could do her arm she
technologies I could have just like
walked in that's an easy place to see it
but why I wouldn't have cared if it was
that one but I cared because then it
became such a big deal in the airplane
where the airplane is that is starting
to ascend and it's like oh no she's
gonna run out of oxygen and she's gonna
get loopy which is what happened
and at any point she could have just
like reached out and like made it like
descend so she wasn't dealing with a
super-powered person or just a normal
human being it was like I'm climbing the
plane and she's like oh and boxes are
kind of hitting her and it's like this
girl like did the most amazing things a
second ago and now they literally said
like she she was just bumping into stuff
and that's what was like stopping her
that's all inconsistent it's right and
this is the last thing I'll say but it
is one that hit me the most I think that
there's a problem with the stakes of the
movie in that she says very clearly
actually really thought so exciting I
was hoping for she did be good she says
I have to destroy my family in order to
save it and I have to break the law in
order to fix the law and I was like oh
both of those things are really cool
let's see them let's feel those things
and I never felt like we actually like
the family's broken we could see like in
a cartoony way like oh no like it and I
go a little like Pixar short kind of way
like the baby's on fire and like he
hasn't finished his homework but didn't
feel like is this the end of the family
which I think what the whole movie was
supposed to be giving us and then the
other thing the laws she wasn't like on
the run at any point they immediately
when they're like are you gonna have to
break the law to fix the law like the
first thing is like the newspaper say
you're doing great everyone's happy and
it's like oh that never mattered right
you're breaking my word that like yeah
the beginning of the movie super heroism
is illegal supers are illegal before the
movie starts or the movie starts and
then basically the villains goal is to
return that place where superheroes are
alright alright yeah yeah and it's just
kind of weird that the superhero isn't
trying or the super villain it's just a
villain he's not trying to change the
world in any way they're just so why did
their plan need to exist at all you know
just because her brother didn't know
what her plan was it's basically the
only justification for that which felt a
little simple I think I agree with with
your criticisms and I by the way like to
the movie yeah yeah but she's talking
very much liked and I think what was
missing for me what made it fall a
little short of the first movies
elegance and fun is when I look at
something like The Incredibles it does
feel a little comic book II it feels
simple like we've all made videos about
Pixar cinematic universes and the one
that was most fun for me is the one you
guys did that basically said movies like
The Incredibles are the comic books and
and TV shows that other characters and
the Pixar universe are watching so that
feels simple syndrome had a very simple
want and a very simple evil
and The Incredibles felt like a very
necessarily oversimplified comic book
story they dealt with some deeper issues
that were really well done but it wasn't
difficult to understand what his plan
was and why he had to be stopped and I
think in the second movie they they made
the villain very complex they had a lot
of conversations there was a lot of
interesting and ran to type theories on
that were being dealt with but at the
end of the day I didn't really
understand what the dramatic stakes were
of the villains plan if they succeeded
at their evil plan and I think with a
with any great comic book story in
infinity war like we knew what the
consequences would be a fan of succeeded
it's all half of reality and what's
great about it you can say it in just a
few words yeah one sound you know is
it's now simplify that is and it works
really well here just felt very
complicated a little muddy a little hard
to understand exactly why we needed be
stopped and how that was a counterpoint
to the hero's goals in the movie so that
was just one thing that for me in the
third act it was like okay I understand
logically what's happening it just felt
like why did why does the villain need
to be stopped why do the heroes need to
go through with it I'm still having fun
watching all the action and I'm enjoying
this right now it's just like in the
third act of the first Incredibles win
Syndrome grabs Jack Jack you feel that
since the panic you know it's like Oh
syndrome cannot succeed in this moment
there it was like kind of a fundamental
crisis at stake and I just didn't
understand on an emotional level what
the fundamental crisis was in the third
act of this movie didn't necessarily
take away from my enjoyment of it it
just didn't necessarily get that a-plus
for me I enjoyed this movie more but I
did have to like clarify that
Incredibles is an A+ and so is this it's
just a point a little bit higher I just
enjoyed this slightly more also I going
into it I'm like it's a kids movie like
you kind of have to like always bring
that back it's a Pixar movie which means
it's approachable for adult audiences
and so with that in mind I did try to
think about like what is the villain
trying to say like you understand this
is like the problem they had as kids
this is what their parents went through
and you're like okay so I understand
what that they're saying I do good get
what you mean I think the threat is
introduced pretty quick
I think I understand your point I might
be misunderstanding we talk later after
the show too but like as soon as she
immediately like sets up the heroes to
murder half of a city like that's that
felt like what the threat was yeah but
they didn't in in the first movie they
brought up like this big kind of like
philosophical question and so this one
tried to but the first one did kind of
answer it and this one didn't it just
kind of like it was kind of like it was
just like mentioned so the audience can
think about it but no one in the movie
decided to think about it at all so it's
like there's there's a fault there and I
do get some of you guys's criticisms as
well but overall it did kind of feel a
little bit tighter for me because I
rewatched the first incredible still
amazing but overall I didn't I didn't
actually have too many critiques of it
yeah I know no and I'll say because a
lot of people will say but maybe Eric
and Phil weren't seeing it as a kids
movie and they should be it's like no
because I would have other complaints I
think the the twist is so incredibly
predictable to adult but I'm like that's
the kind of thing I was like no for a
kid they kind of that is kind of
shocking ago someone we liked is
actually bad but that's not kind of on
talking about like Pixar movies are kids
movies and their amazing stories and
they perfectly come back and in this one
I think just to like simplify and
clarify what what I think maybe both of
us are saying is if the villain had done
nothing and and like we started the
movie we like their ultimate goal is
just end the movie in the same place we
already started status quo being
superheroes illegal second
oh you'll kill a bunch of people because
I'm gonna crash a boat into a building
and then it'll be illegal yeah it's like
it was illegal even even Evelyn had to
do it's not help her brother and right
to her plans would have been but when
would they because he was pretty
headstrong and kind of had the CEO
mindset and was like no we're doing this
and it's going to be done and we're
gonna get using completely all of her
technology or try to talk him out of it
but also it's not like he was that eager
to do it he happened to see them he's
like oh they're out okay I have an idea
mmm and it's like so he had a night like
again if these two characters had just
even if she'd been like let's go on
vacation like just drive around a new
fun thing for him if the whole movie
would not gone to
there's just too much status quo of what
she's trying to get to is like where we
started yeah and it's just we're we're
holding Pixar to a very high standard
that is do they really are the best and
you know what they make kids movies but
they're the kind of kids movies that
adults can enjoy too and feel like a kid
again by combining very complex adults
type themes but putting it in very
simpler terms that kids can actually
inside-out is like is it a master base
yeah and it and it presents things of
what it means to have conflicting
emotions and why you need different
kinds of emotions it's a very complex
idea that like it's great that kids are
thinking about these kind of things so
you know we can hold Pixar to a very
high standard yes sure they're happy to
be to have that conversation too but we
want to have that conversation with you
guys in the comments below let us know
what you thought about this movie how
does it match up with the first
Incredibles movie and other Pixar movies
that you've seen what tell us your
ranking I'm always curious to know like
for me there's like an inner tear Pixar
movies and then an outer to you they're
all and on a plane of greatness but we
want to know what you guys think the
meantime let us move on to or tree a
question this week in the theme of
incredible
so the question is who does the voice of
Edna mode in The Incredibles movies okay
all of our answers are in the bucket
here we will reveal the answer to the
trivia question at the end of the show
the winner will get to do our goodbyes
the loser will have to do our in other
news headlines and try to be funny at
the end of it it's real fun to watch
it's usually a bit of a okay okay before
we move on a quick news update from this
week Marvel held a special panel at
Cinna Europe the convention showing a
footage reel from Captain Marvel and a
video related to Avengers 4 now there's
nothing new to actually show you but we
have the inside scoop here the takeaways
you need to know there was a rumor that
there was an Avengers force scene
between Iron Man and ant-man regarding a
way to go into different realities but
that rumor is not true it was just a
rumor
instead Kevin Feige released a video
explaining a few general details about
the movie to advertisers but we didn't
there was no footage shown there was
apparently a look at the Avengers new
suits
including what attendees described as
new armor for the whole under armour
undershirt more of his real armor there
was also a behind-the-scenes sizzle reel
for Captain Marvel we're still looking
for a shot by shot description we don't
know how much footage was actually shown
there just shots of like craft service
tables or something but the footage
testimonials and interviews with like
brie Larson and the rest of the cast and
Captain Marvel was described as the next
face and leader of the MCU going into
phase 4 it's pretty however we did learn
this week that Marvel will make no firm
announcements about phase 4 until after
2019 Comic Con so it's gonna be a while
and then rumored that I think is
interesting we should bring up that
someone apparently who works or is
associated with the marketing for
Avengers 4 did see the title of the
movie and they said it was three words
the first one being Avengers and the
second two words beginning with F and
then H that's just a rumor we don't know
if it's confirmed or not quick what it
was FH Sam for fun house fallen heroes
that's a fact
we got real fat or some of us move on
horses defeat Danos oh yeah so let us
know what you think
fh we're gonna be doing a lot
speculating we love just like
speculating with like the first letter
of the word like fan o's has to be an
acronym for the infinity stone locations
right so fh we're used to doing this
okay everyone we just got a big preview
for aquaman with several interesting
photos from the movies showing us the
main characters and the undersea kingdom
of Atlantis guys let's run through each
of these break down the stuff you might
have missed the first image that we saw
shows us Aquaman alone Arthur Currie
Jason Momoa as he saves the submarine as
it's being attacked by pirates sounds
like a lot of the action will come from
real-life modern-day piracy which sounds
like it could be the origin of actually
one of the villains who we'll get to in
a bit but next there is a shot of Arthur
curry with Mira played by Amber Heard
there on the surface world they appear
to be exploring some Greek or Roman
ruins presumably some ancient
Mediterranean civilization by the way
Dolph Lundgren is playing Mira's father
King Nereus we haven't seen any shots of
him yet but I'm very excited
next is the shot that everyone is
talking about black manta played by Yaya
Abdul Mateen the second he's looking at
his helmet now director James Wan
promised that black mantas helmet would
look as alien as it does in the comics
it was a joking in the comics the helmet
shoots plasma beams out of the eyes
sound like that happened because in the
Entertainment Weekly description for it
it said they'll raise hell
spelling race RA Y s so I'm sure we'll
see that Black Manta is he's an overseas
mercenary it sounds like he may be
connected with the piracy organization
that Aquaman has to face like it could
be a member of like maybe Somalian
pirates there's something like that
it'll be really fun to see that in
action and it sounds like Black Manta
will just be a supporting villain he's
not gonna be the primary villain we
actually see the primary villain
in the next image we're talking about
ocean master from the comics aka King
worm he's played by Patrick Wilson he's
Aquaman's ambitious half-brother and he
hates surface dwellers and Aquaman of
course is half human so it kind of
creates a natural tension but
clean them so it looks like we're gonna
be seeing a game of Thrones style
political family drama for the throne
may be similar to what black panther was
very interesting dynamic there now the
next image shows the next image shows
this director James Wan with Aquaman
Emira in a sunken ship location looks
very cool there speaking with volcko
he's played by Willem Dafoe volcko is a
mentor to Aquaman and once production
design just looks awesome apparently
we're gonna see gladiator arenas
warriors writing great white sharks
there's just gonna be a lot of cool
things to see can we go back one image
what's fascinating to me is is this
moment underwater right now
yeah nothing so yeah I was James Bond
breathing know it's fascinating that
like they're treating it to have like
the weight of the world you know I mean
like you rest on a table underwater
right yeah and I kind of it sounds like
James 1 it's said that the whole
speaking underwater thing that we don't
I wonder why that was so over thought in
that movie to make up air but we're
referencing yeah so in Justice League in
order to have Aquaman talk they're like
you can't do sound waves it can't happen
something that she has to create an air
bubble so they can just talk and he's
James Bond it's gonna ignore that
completely even though it's the same
universe and say they could have just
talked the whole time and little ripples
fool James 1 ignored it so much he just
took cameras and ruined cameras under
one nearly died no actually that next
photo we were looking at when it was the
arena with the sharks versus the sea
horses look they're sea horses they have
legs that horse this I am this is what
I'm for it when I was like Aquaman movie
sometimes can be like again Aquaman gets
made fun of a lot but also sometimes the
character isn't the most exciting to
read a story about even though people do
like political stories I do but this is
what I'm here for
I'm down for sharks versus seahorses a
hundred percent I'm gonna buy tickets
opening night like I wasn't already
gonna do that it should call it that
yeah man
sharks versus a horse you can see seven
statues pointing their their Trident
together there's seven undersea Kingdom
so when we saw that thing unite the
seven that poster with Jason Momoa
wasn't referring to like a seventh
member of the Justice League including
Green Lantern they're referring to the
Seven Kings ago
so they're gonna be getting into all
that political drama it's gonna feel
like I assume a lot like the kingdoms of
Wakanda coming together
I know DC people get pissed off when we
try to say everything we're not saying
DC ripped this off for a black panther
it's just what you'd liked about black
panther I think you're gonna like yeah I
mean it's the most common war strategy
is to make allies yeah move on to the
last image it shows Nicole Kidman's
character Curry's mother Queen Atlanta
and the image looks like it's part of
maybe a flashback scene with Arthur as a
baby and his parents when they had to
trade him off from land to sea the image
on the cover of Entertainment Weekly of
Nicole Kidman looked a little hokey in
Photoshop but this one looks very
interesting
I love Nicole Kidman I'm really glad
she's gonna be part of this movie now
based off of these images do you guys
think that like Aquaman could be the
breath of fresh air or the breath of
fresh water water seawater ceu needs
because right now they need a kickstart
Wonder Woman provided that but the rest
of the Justice League could probably
need pick-me-up and you think this could
bring it the costumes very interesting I
don't want to say too much until I got
you seeing an action like a trailer
because sometimes just images of them
you're like like I grew to like Flash's
costume still a little overly
complicated and I think Aquaman's was to
some glad it's kind of switching it up a
little bit I did think it was
interesting that it was king arm instead
of usually Prince warm or somebody
because it's you on the throne they're
like they're vying for the throne or she
or Queen Atlanta would be the one who's
on the throne so that's interesting that
it's already progressed that far so that
could be interesting I'm patient but the
set designs beautiful and I like all the
actors in it so hopefully it will be
yeah and I'm really into this idea if
they are doing a game of Thrones
approach because the best Aquaman that
I've read is the version where it is
royal struggles and and those politics
what's always interesting about a
monarchy is that there shouldn't be
politics about who's on the throne and
yet there always are and so and there's
are always life and death because that's
the only way you can get someone like
off the throne but all the best
storylines are with that idea and that
side and not so much dealing with like
like how they just trying to they try to
merge like land problems with with the
water and it's like oil tankers is like
the idea that they always have and he's
always mad because of the dolphins but
it's like he's a king
the arable can be and has drama like in
place yeah I'm gonna love his bro he
talked in the middle of a war like
council I like that a lot I like that I
did like that sits on the lasso like
that was maybe the one really good
awkward moment for me watching Jeff he
went to school and yeah he became a
normal dude yeah I crunch ah he could
and you know it like they are using if
you just look at the filmmaking strategy
here they're filling the rest of the
cast of the really really great
performers like Willem Dafoe is awesome
Lundgren is gonna be part of this movie
I I think this could be really really
fun movie I if it ends up being a bomb I
know you're gonna clip this out later
and be like I feel like this would be
really really fun movie but I like Jason
Momoa in this part I like his depiction
of the character and I hope this is good
because I I think Aquaman deserves a
movie that's not the Vinnie chase
version and let us know what you hope to
see most from this movie and hopefully a
trailer will be coming soon of course
we'll be doing a full breakdown of it
but based off of these shots and James
wants such a great director I'm really
excited to see what Warner Brothers and
the DCU is able to pull off here ok
another big news update from this week
guys HBO announced that they have picked
up a game of Thrones prequel series
produced by george RR martin and Jane
Goldman Jane Goldman borough at movies
like x-men first class and Days of
Future past kick-ass all the Matthew
Vaughn movies the Kingsmen movies she's
she's really really good the series
description is as follows taking place
thousands of years before the events of
Game of Thrones the series chronicles
the world's descent from the Golden Age
of Heroes into its darkest hour and the
only one and only one thing is for sure
from the horrifying secrets of Westeros
is history - the true origin of the
White Walkers the mysteries of the east
and Starks of legend it's not the story
we think final season of Game of Thrones
may not give us all the answers to all
the mysteries like the White Walkers the
children in the forest bran the Builder
the doom of Valyria yeah Ra's al Ghul
yeah but because now we'll get to a
whole new series that goes into that so
yeah
that's me because I'm making some
predictions for the
final season of Game of Thrones may not
answer all the mythology questions or I
mean it's gonna answer them in like the
snippets that are going to be like
technical and literal like this is what
happened maybe right but what we know
because like imagine the complexity of
Game of Thrones and then a thousand
years later this idea takes place I
think a thousand years before but
imagine a thousand years after Game of
Thrones they're not gonna have
flashbacks to the seasons of Game of
Thrones we'd see like okay Ned Stark
it's behead like we'd see like just
these things I think we're gonna have
understanding like that but then we're
gonna have the intricate understanding
of like why the you know why they're the
White Walkers were created like like
with the full understanding just I think
there's so much story to tell they're
super excited for by the way also this
is one of the five ideas the HBO was
producing and they still said they might
produce and pick up more than one of
them yeah I mean it wouldn't be the
worst idea I'd understand we have two
Game of Thrones 17 DC shows see a
prequel that maybe takes right before
the events like I'd love to see a
Robert's rebellion prequel I want to see
the Battle of the Trident at some point
maybe we can do it through flashback
when I don't think we'll see it we have
six more episodes left six more movies
left yeah they're gonna be long and we
find it
okay everyone it was a big week for DC
news in major details about the future
of Batman Aquaman Wonder Woman and the
flash but according to The Hollywood
Reporter head of DC entertainment from
Warner Brothers Walter Armada may be
considering the change of course toward
the villains of the DC Universe and a
brand that they might be calling DC dark
or DC black so just summarize the
transition that we're seeing here the
Batman that's the upcoming Batman solo
movie directed by Matt Reeves now has a
script that he turned in over Memorial
Day weekend that features Bruce Wayne as
a younger man
that means Ben Affleck is officially no
longer part of the project we don't know
who will be playing them yet but that
sounds like where they're going with it
and the upcoming flash movie will start
shooting in 2019 with the filmmakers
aiming for a Back to the Future vibe is
the cultural touchstone that they're
saying to think in your head about and
that will come after Aquaman which drops
in December of this year of course and
Shazam and Wonder Woman will come out
next year so that's looking like we'll
see a flash movie in 2020 perhaps
meanwhile it sounds like the Arkham
Asylum that is the DCE you might be
start
to be run by the inmates so there are
two Joker movies in the works a
micro-budget Joaquin Phoenix origin
story directed by Todd Phillips start
shooting this fall and a follow-up movie
that Jared Leto will star in an obeah
follow-up to suicide squad that version
of Joker now they also planned for
Margot Robbie to reprise Harley Quinn in
the upcoming birds of prey with the
penguin rumored as the villain of that
movie so I'm curious to hear from you
guys do you think this idea of a DC dark
or DC black could save the DC franchise
is this the direction we want to go in
no also Robert Zemeckis was in talks to
direct the flash and now you want to do
a Back to the Future vibe movie you
missed it now you got a do flashpoint
even if you don't want it you got to I'm
fine with them doing a more back to the
future like make it fun and well because
like I reread flashpoint recently I was
like did I dislike it as much as I
thought like that there's cool things
that happen in it no no doubt I mean it
still my favorite flash story in terms
of like the plot it's it's really cool
and he's the main focus of it but it's
it's his fault
about what's happening so it's like it's
like when the hero bungles and like sets
off a noop it's like don't worry I could
fix this and it's like well you bungled
it though and you don't fix it yeah I'm
glad they're going with a more Back to
the Future vibe still don't understand
why they do two joker movies I get it
money I understand that but like for
real like really getting specifically to
the question of DC dark or DC black I
think that isn't necessarily the worst
strategy to go about because yeah
Batman's rogues gallery I think has been
underrepresented and it is one if you're
thinking strategically with the source
material I think the villains of the DC
Universe are deeper interesting in some
ways and the Marvel ones in Feige and
the rest of his team has done a really
good job to translate characters like
low-key and Thanos and to people that we
really present and are excited to see
but right they're already on the page
you have fascinating characters that I
think if you're gonna make movies yeah
I'd love to see a you know a Lex Luthor
IV you know and I don't have a problem
with him going in that direction I don't
think it's the worst thing I don't know
if it's exactly what they need right now
they have good characters in the flash
and in Batman that you in Nightwing that
you could make into great movies yeah it
just good put good put good people
behind them it just seems like they
could just take a breath like just like
it sounds like it sounds like it's just
like
trying to like out-think themselves with
ideas and it's like yeah you already
like you said though with the villains
like you have you have an idea like if I
will say if like DC dark DC black
however it this works out if you had
like hero stories here villain stories
here they come together and the thing
that they pitch to the Legion of Doom
versus or whatever you want to call them
Justice League versus the Justice League
that's a cool idea when that finally be
their version of that MCU slow roll out
instead of the rush job where's more
like no we are just rolling out the
heroes now we're gonna slow roll out the
villains or something like I know you're
saying I'm getting same vibe as you
though too right that there's some room
that's just filled with sweat and like
bulletin boards and like Louie like how
do we fix this right and they've like
come up with every idea they can I think
you're right the villains isn't a bad
one there's a big difference between
Marvel character designs and DC
character designs and that Marvel heroes
are pretty what is it like mono powered
like they've got like their thing and
like that's their thing and so it's not
the craziest thing to defeat them if you
can just undo their one power and then
in DC these their heroes are overpowered
I mean Batman is a human and he's the
smartest man alive and a billionaire
like I mean he knows every form of
martial arts yeah when he can invent
anything yeah these these characters are
very overpowered but that's why I think
like you know we get so excited about
them but then in order to create
villains I would challenge them at all
they had to make these like really
interesting intense villains for Batman
spread out but yeah but between Batman
and Superman you got some of the best
villains that are out there period
because the characters are so
overpowered that in order to actually be
a challenge you had to come up with
equally good villains so if there is a
bet to make I guess it's this one yeah
and I mean look we're all like armchair
commentators like it's it's hard to run
a movie studio and it's hard to be
competitive it's hard to adapt things in
a way to satisfy every fan so we don't
have all the answers but let's like talk
about of the movies that we've heard now
being announced what are you most
excited to see what character do you
want to see be the face of the DC
Cinematic Universe going forward is it a
different new version of Batman is it
Margot Robbie's take on Harley Quinn
there's a lot of different directions we
can go but what are you most excited to
see
how many joker movies do you give us a
number but as always subscribe the new
rock stars for all of our takes on this
we're gonna start talking more and more
about DC characters in the DC Universe
going forward because we love these
characters and we're as excited to see
what comes next as you guys are but now
let's move on to our new arc stars news
lightning round you guys as possible
oh boy Phillip Dillon straggly on
Twitter wants to know what is the most
disappointing movie sequel ever
oh god Independence Day oh yeah yeah
yeah the potential there even their
premise was so good actually that after
the aliens attack we get their
technology and we have it ready for when
they come back and then they did bungle
the whole thing yeah yeah alright Sam at
sam EG 1 2 3 to 7 wants to know what was
your favorite reveal from e3 and why I
mean oh sorry
reveal Super Smash Bros ultimate because
we're getting everybody back makes me so
happy
we got toon link you got youngling you
got ray but not the week this was the
answer so question this one said at
treks wild Eric if you had a
velociraptor if what would you name him
one special call would he respond to
okay name Littlefoot is that the land of
before time and then okay well I don't
know what special I'll just do my best
Raptor oh it's a little Rick from
Walking Dead yeah Coral get inside come
on you left the show too early
I'm gonna leave the show to why still on
TV this show should have been cancelled
three years ago give us a call car all
right
thanks for everybody for it tweeted us
this question it's always great to hear
from you guys the next up let's take a
look at what we got in the pipeline four
videos coming out on this channel in the
next week we're gonna do a breakdown of
Incredibles 2 all the Easter eggs and
Pixar references that you might have
missed we're on the lookout for an
Aquaman trailer 2 we got it's coming
it's coming they said we're surprised
it's not already out because the
Entertainment Weekly did a spread
normally that precedes an actual trailer
but I'm sure everyone's saying it's
coming soon when it comes out we'll do a
breakdown also we got another very
exciting project in the works yeah we
can say that we've said ok big
announcement guys we're gonna be doing a
rewatch breakdown of the Christopher
Nolan Dark Knight trilogy boom 10 years
10 years since 12 years or 13 years
since the original Batman Begins but
we're coming up on the 10-year
anniversary of the Dark Knight in in
July so yeah we're very excited we're
going back to look at all the deeper
reasons why it's so great all the
interesting cinematic choices that were
made and references and in ways that
Nolan adapted this a character in a way
that we've never seen before so ten
years ago Eric and I drove like hours to
go see snippets of Dark Knight we were
very poor and we had to stand on each
other's shoulders like over the fence
cuz they're playing a baseball stadium
we're supposed to be painting that fence
but but it started this journey of what
we do now of like obsessing over these
movies and being like holy crap these
movies sometimes are the best movies
being made why is no one talking about
them that way and that's what this whole
channel became and that's super
interesting because I don't think I've
revisited Batman Begins I really enjoyed
it when it came out I know there's a lot
of and now as a casual Batman fan then
and now more of a hardcore Batman fan
I'd be really interested to see where
all the little Easter rings on yeah yeah
I mean this before that was actually
like the fun thing for people to point
out and obsess over or so they actually
didn't like a lot of people knock on
back and actually shown how they
readapted for instance Batman year one
and exactly what ways in order to make
that man begin yeah and it's cool to see
like little choices Nolan made and as
you still figured out the tone
it before he got to the Dark Knight
which I feel like is like the perfect
version of what he want to do with that
man but to see Batman Begins like he's
kind of laying the groundwork for that
kind of movie to come a couple years
later so we're doing all three movies
three yeah so stay tuned for more
announcements about that we're very very
excited about that but now it comes to
the time for a 15-second shout out where
each of us has 15 seconds to shout out
plug Ram about anything we want Sam why
don't you start okay I mentioned it
before but I'll say it now the
spider-man game looks incredible I
already pre-ordered it as well as
Kingdom Hearts 3 got a release date
thank God I'm ready for it it's not
gonna live up to the hype but I'm ready
for it yeah for my 15 seconds I'm not
gonna change fan culture at all but guys
look we'd love all your support for the
different things we break down I had
some guy cussed me out for us not doing
Westworld breakdowns anymore if you're
apologizing to us on Twitter let us know
what you want us to see but like realize
we're people were not a huge operation
here
three people are in this office our beds
are there our kitchens there and like we
have to pick our battles our fanbase is
bigger than one TV show and realize like
yeah we also talked about Marvel and we
talked about DC and Star Wars there's
lots of things that we like to talk
about here we can't drop everything and
cover your favorite TV show even though
we've made videos about in the past we
gotta pick our battles and we'll try to
do other things but like be civil all
right don't take a dick there's a
shout-out to civility yeah yeah that's
my shadow and reminder if you want to
cuss us out in person 15 seconds I
VidCon will be there and you can just
really let us have it and let us know we
won't be able avoid it because you're
standing right there you might even
bring you up on camera you can really
just just lay into it yeah and this
could be you will hope you can replace
us as hosts if you see what happens when
you're on the screen and what happens
when the Internet is able to oh yeah
let's flip it on you so great when your
faces on camera anyway
okay or trivia question that we just to
remind everyone what it was we wanted to
know who does a voice of Edna mode in
The Incredibles movie let's see what do
we wait Eric can you do an impression of
Edna real quick just so we're all on the
same page darling you have to let me
design all your things no capes great
yeah Erin same week boy oh boy
I have Eric's and Eric says John
Ratzenberger John Ratzenberger voice of
the mold
he's an embryo he's in everyone on it
he's the big rigging car's grown man on
cheers yeah yeah playing this character
just learn the judges no yeah doesn't
son right but it's a Pixar guess Philip
said Zsa Zsa Gabor in brooch she might
be dead the designer who I believe is
dead but she has this exact voice yes is
based on Zsa Zsa probably not a bad
guess but what if it seems right and Sam
said Bradbury
where's Mary the correct answer he did
the voice and then they tried to find
someone who could do the voice like his
when he pitched what the character
should sound like and no one did a good
job so they picked the he just did the
voice that's cool
yeah but Sam dude who lost between I
think she might be dead too it's very
much alive I mean I'll do it but I won't
be happy about it okay Sam's our winner
Sam we'll do our good-byes Philip we'll
do our in other news headlines all say
the headline Phil have to come up with a
joke after each one I believe in you
Phillip jokes are fun when you're forced
to do them are you ready all right in
other news according to reports a
Hawkeye standalone movie is being
considered for Marvel's phase 4 Hawkeye
is gonna have a standalone movie because
his family's gonna leave him okay also
another news stranger things is
releasing a telltale game here's the
tale I'll tell about stranger things
it's not that weird anymore and those
kids are gonna grow to be normal freaks
you shaking I've got a lot of rage also
another news George Lucas said that his
plan for the Star Wars movies after
Return of the Jedi was to further
explain the science of the force
including the race called the Wills shut
up
No will you shut up I hope you will
drink a gallon of Mitte chlorine and
shut up George Lucas I've got no more
will for this my phone's ringing on my
watch it's George Lucas okay venom
director Ruben Fleischer didn't rule out
the possibility of a spider-man cameo in
the venom movie
I cameo the movie should be called
spider-man and venom should make a cameo
in it ha take a take
and finally Aquaman director James Wan
said that characters underwater would
just talk to each other and that fans
were overthinking it with the air
bubbles I mean that's true they they
just were and you know you really should
just talk because that's honestly the
thing that is the hardest for us to do
is just talk to each other as human
beings we don't overcomplicate it
hot day great hike I'll take alright Sam
you can take away our goodbyes take us
take us out Oh hold on get it right hold
on man my ears look enormous and I wear
this ah thank you for watching this
week's episode of new rockstars news
we'll see you guys at VidCon make sure
you follow us all on Twitter I'm at Sam
basher over here Eric Voss at EA Voss
for more information and give mine you
look like you have a head wound comment
it's pulling my eye up comment down
below and tweet us new rock stars only
nice things though you don't want to
hear that bad stuff like this video
share and around and subscribe to new
rock stars for deep dives into the stuff
you love we'll see you guys next week
bye I have my mask on we're gone my
favorite joke also was the how do i
uncrushed yeah